Traductor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
¿Qué es la realidad, el conocimiento?
¿Cuál es el sentido de la vida?
Grandes temas que podrías
abordar figurativamente
explicando la existencia como un viaje
por un camino o por el océano,
una escalada, una guerra, un libro,
un carrete de hilo,
un juego, una ventana de oportunidad,
o un parpadeo demasiado corto de
la vida de una llama.
Hace 2400 años,
uno de los pensadores
más famosos de la historia
dijo que la vida es
como estar encadenado en una cueva,
obligado a ver sombras que
revolotean por una pared de piedra.
Bastante alegre, ¿verdad?
Fue lo que en realidad sugirió Platón
en su alegoría de la caverna,
incluida en el libro VII
de "La República",
en la que el filósofo griego imagina
la sociedad ideal
analizando conceptos como
justicia, verdad y belleza.
En la alegoría, un grupo de presos
ha sido confinado a una caverna
desde su nacimiento, de espaldas
a la entrada, sin poder girar la cabeza,
y sin el conocimiento del mundo exterior.
Ocasionalmente, gente y otras cosas pasan
por delante de la entrada de la cueva,
proyectando sombras y ecos en la pared
que ven los cautivos.
Los prisioneros nombran y
clasifican estas ilusiones,
creyendo que perciben entidades reales.
De repente, un preso es liberado
y llevado fuera por primera vez.
La luz hiere sus ojos y encuentra
el nuevo entorno desorientador.
Cuando le dicen que las cosas
alrededor son reales,
mientras que las sombras eran
meros reflejos, no puede creerlo.
Las sombras le parecían mucho más claras.
Pero poco a poco, sus ojos se adaptan
hasta poder mirar
los reflejos en el agua,
los objetos directamente,
y finalmente el Sol,
cuya luz es la fuente última
de todo lo que ha visto.
El prisionero vuelve a la cueva
para compartir su descubrimiento,
pero ya no se acostumbra a la oscuridad,
y tiene dificultad para ver
las sombras en la pared.
Los otros prisioneros creen que
el viaje lo ha hecho estúpido y ciego,
y se resisten violentamente a
cualquier intento de ser liberados.
Platón presenta este pasaje
como una analogía
de lo que se siente siendo un filósofo
tratando de educar al público.
La mayoría de las personas
no solo está cómoda en su ignorancia
sino que es hostil a cualquier
persona que la señala.
De hecho, en la vida real Sócrates
fue condenado a muerte
por el gobierno ateniense
por perturbar el orden social,
y su alumno Platón pasa
gran parte de "La República"
despreciando la democracia ateniense,
mientras fomenta el estado
dirigido por reyes filósofos.
Con la parábola de la cueva,
Platón puede que argumente que las
masas son demasiado tercas e ignorantes
para autogobernarse.
Pero la alegoría ha capturado
la imaginación durante 2400 años
porque se puede interpretar
de muchas más formas.
Es importante destacar que la alegoría
está conectada a la teoría de las formas,
desarrollada en otros diálogos de Platón,
que sostienen que,
como las sombras en la pared,
las cosas en el mundo físico son
reflejos imperfectos de formas ideales,
tales como la redondez o la belleza.
De esta manera, la cueva lleva
a muchas cuestiones fundamentales,
incluyendo el origen del conocimiento,
el problema de la representación,
y la naturaleza de la realidad misma.
Para los teólogos, existen las formas
ideales en la mente de un creador.
Los filósofos del lenguaje ven
las formas como conceptos lingüísticos,
la teoría ilustra el problema
de agrupar cosas concretas
bajo términos abstractos.
Y otros aún se preguntan
si realmente podemos saber
que las cosas fuera de la cueva
son más reales que las sombras.
Al ir viviendo,
¿podemos estar seguros de lo
que creemos que sabemos?
Tal vez un día,
un rayo de luz perfore un agujero
en tus verdades más básicas.
¿Te liberarás luchando hacia la luz,
incluso a costa de perder amigos
y familiares,
o seguirás en la ilusión cómoda
y familiar?
¿Verdad o hábito? ¿Luz o sombra?
Decisiones difíciles, pero si te sirve
de consuelo, no estás solo.
Hay un montón de nosotros aquí abajo.